Oh yeah, it's working. Thankfully.
Okay so so my name
is Arthur I'm Brazilian and
I'm 17 years old.
Okay, I'ma tell you I
am from Colombia. I am
19. And yeah that's okay
though as I said before
there are those questions that
we we can we can
kind of use them as
a guideline but we can
of course, talk about other
things, other topics that are
related to. Okay. We can
start by the first question.
Do you want to reply
first?
I don't know.
I don't really think like,
Even foreign like from your
experiences abroad. What can you
say about cultural differences? Do
you think the countries? You've
been are different. How
Okay, I think I can
start. The only time I've
been to Brazil was when
I went to Mexico and
2016 and I I didn't
feel that much of a
cultural difference because I was
traveling with my aunt and
it was 14. So I
was not able to go
out by myself and talk
to people. So I wasn't
really emerged to the cold
trip and I and also
I didn't spend as much
time as I was only
there for 10 days, so,
I think one of the
cultural difference that I, that
I felt was that in
Mexico. They had a much
more laid-back attitude towards foreigners
first temple. They, they didn't
care because I because I
feel like people really have
that, like, Greenville cultures around
the world, but I don't
know why. But overall I
feel like Mexico and Brazil
share a lot of similarities
and I think that's because
it's so yeah.
We can talk about you.
Now, I've been to Mexico
City to the states. I've
been to multiple states on
the gestational kind of
Not late enough. Experience to
answer the question, I didn't
think it depends a lot
on visitation people to receive
like the way they would
react to older people. Like
you puts a when I
went to Canada I never
feel like I was out
of the culture that it
wasn't like it was in
the state. I always feel
like a no-brainer because she'll
want to stay here until
I speak English. Do you
know that? You don't think
it's native guy or that
you don't belong there and
you feel constantly like you're
going to the reminder that
you are not part of
that siding. But for sure.
Like
Represent the same people, I
don't know because some people
here will react to people
speaking foreign languages in the
street. Like it was Tara
you like why were you
saying what you're speaking? Like,
I don't know where we
are in Columbia supposed to
speak in Norway in or
whatever. So this like you
snakes and you can see
how you are because you're
not like any indication like
towards like this topic. I'm
okay lately. So
I think that that have
changed a lot how people
used to react to foreigners
because now when you see
if in the swelling and
Street people Will Ferrell then
they will swing by there.
People or something. Or less
work people. So I will
say that the most people
can point immigrants or foreigners
and you know because like
Before you didn't see any,
I mean, a lot of
things because before I would
never see Universal Patrol or
immigration police officers or immigration.
You won't see anything at
all as the people that's
a password on your iPad
that, like, your developers came
in. There was no immigration
system, or if you came
from Germany, they were like,
okay, you can stay as
long as you want.
so,
what was the question again?
Went to the states. I've
been to say, smoothly on
winter, so I feel like
there's a little closer difference
between how people acting with
your time than we do
because it wasn't the first
to confirm on France like
to face the winter if
the patient's life, even sorry,
we don't have seen something.
So, when I get there
I just found one in
the state and they would
like you to bring enough
clothes. And it was like,
what will I need that?
Because, and they would like
he does his fucking freezing
outside.
So it's very cool to
see them to drink, iced
coffee, even feel like fighting
with outside outside. What was
you? Be drinking iced coffee.
If it's freaking freezing, react
to things for Central. We
are at. So used to
convert, Apple to see that
we are so used to
have mountains around us, like
the whole city is basically.
How do you say?
This is what I'm started.
Forgetting English. How do you
like a continuous?
Mongering thing. Like you can
say it in Spanish.
Yeah, I think it's a
mountain range. So we are
so that was like literally
the first I went to
Miami for the first time
I went out to Columbia
was for going to Miami
on when I got there
I was like so sure
of that or out of
the one. I went to
the same thing like I
don't see a mountain around
me until that little inmates,
may be feeling like everything
was closer. I don't know
because I didn't see the
limit like okay, so you
can go when you're not
going to order and they
see that that's where the
city and the state I
didn't see any month. And
so I will sing like,
okay, there is no limit
to go. I mean, you
can go as far as
you par drive to you
or whatever you decide about
it this way because I
went to Mexico City and
it was actually the other
way around.
I would just remember on
the last day, we weren't
going back to school and
on the bus to the
airport. I just saw, I
saw it snow for the
first time, but it was,
it was no go on
the top of the mountain
and I thought it was
so beautiful. That was surrounded
by mountains and I don't
know. I never thought it
this way, I just said
that they finish without those
kind of mountain, don't have
any limits. I think it's,
it's funny now that he
said, it's another perspective or
point of view,
did you let Siri say
that somebody's called, like okay
this person, so cold, or
is or some like that,
but you mean that this
person like is not like
pretty
Are going or whatever. But
I think they would have
has a lot to do
with that because for several
people, in this state and
Miami are leaving like a
more warmer.
Play. Do you know my
love mobile? I'm going to
Boston for a sample or
Canada, so people are more
happy. I have your sorry.
I'll Xavier are like more
open and stuff like that
winter. People was like, he
didn't even know who you
never watch out for the
person that it was in
front of you. And I
say this because my family
lives, there I am in
part of my family lives
in Boston.
And they they seem like
I've been living in the
same neighborhood at my own
say that I believe in
you just hang there for
20 years and the only
time I get to know
who lives in my surroundings
is in summer time because
it's the only time people
go out. So I'd like
to shape the way we
are closer. It was cool
to show for me not
to know who lived in
the house next to you,
like Nazi people on the
street or the only people
that will talk to, you
will be the people that
we're working for you or
pretend we're in a restaurant.
The only people that will
talk to you where they
your waiters or you were
in the Metro only domestic
worker. Nobody will ever it
that were to you or
whatever or something that anything
was like searching for me
because we are used to
be a lot more friendly
and I don't know.
We have something similar in
Brazil, not now that you
said it because I feel
like he is such a
pretty much all the time
and there are the beaches
and people are more friendly
in general and in some
Paulo friends and it's just
feel like I just feel
like people are much more
closed the weather but I
don't know that much difference.
Some Paulo is a bit
colder. It gets cold for
Brazilian standard for simple 9:10,
but where was I?
What was supposed to stay
with their depression? I think
people have on their phones
are listening to music.
Yeah. It's like I said
I mean you can upload
it becomes of being cold
figuratively, or actually like on
paper, like people actually get
cold in color whether it's
like, you know what I
mean by. That is acceptable
in the town. Treat you
visited as a foreigner but
not in the country you
from
Okay, if it's real thin,
my country to not answer
to Strangers. Like if somebody
says, can you some things
you might pay attention to
what he's saying, but in
the state did you ask
somebody something to somebody and
that person doesn't feel like
I'm doing. Did you go?
They will do just caused
by New Yorker. Story are
so mean I'm so if
you talk to people on
people's like in the garage
or you're busy or whatever
do you say oh I'm
sorry I can't or whatever.
They was just
When are the CMA Country?
People will stop and show
you help? I don't know.
I think, yeah.
Yeah, I've never felt this
difference because in Brazil, something
like that, I can't think
of any habits that is
coming in Brazil, and not
coming to Mexico and I
can't think of anything. What
did you say? As I
said before, that's one reason
why?
Oh, okay. Because like I
feel I felt when it
wasn't the states that he
was, he was weird to
me to get sleep because
I can't read you, never
literally never see people. And
it was like what you
have to tip you. I'm
really paying for the lease
and I'm the only tip
like mostly on restaurants when
we want to. It's not
something mandatory and I don't
know if it's true, but
I've heard that in the
United States, you never know
what the final price going
to be because you have
to talk later.
How can I say? I
forgot the word but it's
not a really, it's not
really good. When you have
a certain amount of money
in your bank account and
you have and you have
to spend money but you
just don't know what can
you buy? Because you have
to either be there because
I wanted to buy a
pookie.
Like how do you say
that? Like I told you
I can see the point
is that he was so
big that it was like
oh my God I need
to try this. When it
was going to pay the
girl was like okay it's
true to life is around
$15 and I was like,
okay who's your $50? And
she was like okay it's
1699 I would like
That's actually something that because
for instance, iPhone Spirit are
so not only iPhones, but
Apple product to buy to
somebody else, you want to
be lost much cheaper because
I'm not really sure about
the percentage, but I think
at least half of the
size of the natural products
or or less, the more
or less have is only
texts entirely sure, but it's
still on.
Same here. For example, I
bought my phone. I mean,
I have an iPhone 7
something and I remembered that
I'd buy it and just
stay because it was so
much cheaper than to buy
in Columbia at because before,
I mean, there was like
a $200 difference between the
price in the state and
the price in Columbia. So
I wasn't ready going to
the states. Like I was
like, okay, I'm going to
stay anyway, so I'm going
to buy you a phone.
It doesn't make sense to
buy things for me because
you're going to be so,
so, so expensive to cigarette,
companies lake flato, or
Or mobistar. I don't know
the name of the phone
companies in Brazil, right? I
think they're right about where
you want to show people.
Why is it not a
free-market? Like there's a website
where you can actually see?
Where is it? Where is
cheaper? Diesel official Apple Store.
Sometimes it's cheaper to Temple.
I was looking for a
Macbook and
Journey by their recent Raziel
and actually, it would be
cheaper so weird. Like people
like the chemistry sign is
a peace deal with the
gorillas in gorillas sound so
much like us. And when
they sign, is the tax,
for the vortex was removed
because this country was supposed
not to be in war
anymore but like the Gorillaz
King Bach resource rate with
the dealer anymore so they're
start again on stuff like
that. So the war tax
is on again like they're
charging to work again and
do you have to pay
the war? That is not
even affecting me? I mean
I think it's so selfish
to say that I don't
want to pay for the
war that I'm not want
to be part of the
country that didn't work, but
just leave in or the
conditions that live in it.
I mean, I am never
affect by War and I
have never,
I have never seen a
shooting, I have never seen.
Somebody gets killed around the
secure. Never because I leave
in like dude, part of
the country or if you
did because we are part
of like a higher than
the meeting of the society.
I guess. I mean I
hate the directions to go
to university because your parents
are most wealthy and I
was like, okay so I
warned more but like I
do have to pay for
the war and I like
How do you say that
word?
What do you call the
amount of money does?
Did the surname division of
the government has to spend
something the budget and fiscal
budget for the ministry of
the patient and like that's
why we have work because
you are not the best
indication, that's why people stupid.
Yeah, actually, I'm sorry, I
say Pollito party back in
the 70s, I guess their
main purpose. I mean, their
sole purpose was to defeat
the government on that moment
because Ethan mom in Columbia,
we have a president that
I don't remember the name.
But he was kind of
like Tater so they can
realize it started as a
way to defeat this president,
or at least, that is
what I have read and
see my flight. Let you
know, the national interests of
people like Regular People. Like
how do you say, like,
in Pueblo? Like
Okay, first of the working
class that makes like 80%
of the population of the
country. So everything is start
fine. Randomly the band started
doing.
I forgot to wear it
like a talk.
Oh my God, I forget
to work like, I guess
for temple today.
Paula I was there a
president I guess it's called.
Sorry, is where did most
of the people? Is the
capital get sentenced to life.
How do you say that
before you go to jail?
Do you get to go
to the judge? And he
gives you the fact that
you mean the cord, they
they they used to help
people there like people that
was not a yes or
how come you don't know
yet. I'm supposed to help
people that are because they
have like two jails in
there like to decorate people
on the ministry of I
don't know what wasn't there.
And so they kidnapped and
after that is staring attacking
and recycling
Station just to see how
the attention that is, why
you have to the point
to the point that in
2016, the president sign an
agreement with them not to
fight anymore because they were
super cool already.
But I didn't care, so
they came back to the
war, you know, I know
you hate it, so the
opposition military. So what about
the fork is inside a
category?
I don't know. I don't
remember her name for e
l. I n e for
I do remember the name
of them but they're like
for that other groups fall
into because it's just like
the people that go against
the military that's basically I
guess I'm to end our
conversation. So yeah.
40.
No, I think it's it's
28 here in mind. I
don't know. Oh yeah, I
have every faith in it
was good that we had
this discussion and I'd like
to thank you for taking
part of it as project.
Okay, and I think that's
it for now.
Yo, it's so it's so
retarded.
Okay, so is your friends
and I watch this later,
I would like to apologize
for my English, a free
printable ride on stuff like
that. So if something I
did say you'd understand, you
can ask me, like, hey,
what are you saying, this
and I will answer it.
Like, let me just tell
you something, you don't have
to apologize because we were
able to talk about discuss
about complex situations and complex,
the topic, and you really
fine. Many people can't do
this. When people are aliens
real,
Yes, I'll be proud of
yourself and yeah.
7 year of them. That
would be weird. Like like
later I'm going to be
like singing all these like
oh my God, Somebody's Watching
what it says like.